these are the five craziest appearances  of the mysterious character Panda man in  one piece number five if you remove the  dusk jacket of the Japanese volumes many  have a secret version of the art that  features Panda man and number four often  in the background of One Piece chapters  panaman is just there fighting a  mysterious criminal organization called  the Tomato gang we love to think that  this makes panaman a hero but number  three panaman can also be seen at the  slave Auction House on Saba ODI  archipelago is Panda man complicit in  human trafficking and number two we have  Panda man being a member of Nolan's crew  400 years ago so just how old is Panda  man and number one what is the most wild  of it all well you can actually see  Panda man written on the pony glyph in  Alabaster was pandaman a part of the  ancient Kingdom itself